It really started when I was about 13.
I was a junior high school student and,
um,
I met this librarian who's kind of an eccentric person,
very well educated person,
and she,
we,
I used to hang around with my delinquent friends in the library,
which tells you how eccentric the librarian was because that's not normally the
place where the delinquent kids hang out,
you know?
But she talked to us like we were adults and that was a,
what would you call it,
a refreshing.
That was a refreshing experience.
And uh,
she knew that I liked to read and she started giving me real books.
She gave me one day in the life of Ivan Denisovich,
which was the first book published by Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn in the Soviet
Union.
It's,
it's a story about the day of a political prisoner in a,
in a,
in a work camp and brave new world and 1984 and animal farm and Ayn Rand's
books,
which was quite interesting because she was the wife of our member of parliament
who was the only member of the opposition in our province.
And he was a socialist and NDP new Democratic Party leader as a matter of fact.
And,
but despite that,
she gave me Ayn Rand's books because she thought that I should be exposed to the
other side of the argument.
So I read atlas shrugged and,
um,
the fountain head and well,
she was the first person who helped me discover literature,
let's say.
And while at the same time I got interested in what had happened in Nazi
Germany.
Then I wrote an essay about that when I was about 13 or 14 about Auschwitz and
what had happened there.
And I never read that,
really never left my mind.
I would say,
I think I read Viktor Frankl's man's search for meaning at that point,
which is a book I would highly recommend.
I have a reading list on my website by the way,
at Jordan B.
Peterson Dotcom.
And so there's a variety of books there that have really influenced me and I put
them up for other people's,
um,
use.
Anyways.
I never,
what I learned about Auschwitz and about Nazi Germany never really left my mind.
And because I couldn't understand how people could act that way,
how they could not only be possessed by an ideology to the degree that the
Germans were in a very civilized country,
Germany,
you know,
so it was,
I suppose even a more spectacular shock that something so catastrophic happened
there.
There wasn't just the ideological possession,
it was the cruelty and the gratuitous cruelty in the service of that ideological
possession that I couldn't understand.
It didn't,
I couldn't establish a relationship between my own being and,
and those patterns of action.
And as I got older,
that concern transformed itself into an obsession.
I would say not so much with what had happened to Nazi Germany,
but with,
I think what happened,
what was happening as a consequence of the collectivist philosophy per se,
which you might think of something that manifested itself both on the right in
Nazi Germany and then on the left in all the multitudeness and catastrophic
communist regimes that characterized the bulk of the 20th century.
And they're insane.
Murderousness and that probably culminated for me in the 1970s when I Read
Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn the Gulag archipelago,
which is another book that everyone should read because in some sense it might
be the defining document of the 20th century.
And the fact that everyone in the West isn't familiar with that book is actually
a signal of our catastrophic moral failing,
I would say.
Um,
I started writing this book called maps of meaning in about 1985 although I had
been working on variants of it before that.
And what I was trying to understand was maybe the psychological
motivations for the Cold War,
something like that.
Many of you are old enough to remember what it was like in the 1980s we just
went and visited the house in,
in Reykjavik where Gorbachev and Reagan met,
which was quite something to see.
And when they decided they were going to bring at least some of the insanity to
irrelative halt,
thank God.
And the 80s were a very contentious time.
You know,
the Cold War sort of peaked in two at two times a peaked in 1962 during the
Cuban missile crisis.
I don't know if you know this,
but I w I visited a uh,
nuclear missile site in Arizona
both 10 years ago.
It was a decommissioned missile site,
intercontinental ballistic missile,
intercontinental ballistic missile is a very large rocket and can go halfway
around the world and its ballistic,
which means it has the same function as a bullet.
And the bullet is ballistic because once you fire it,
it's gone.
You don't control it after it.
It leaves.
So once you launch a ballistic missile,
it's launched,
there's no calling back.
And they told us they did a simulation launch,
which was very eerie thing.
And so to launch a nuclear missile is a big console.
It sort of looks like the star Trek control a control module,
let's say.
And One person stands here.
One person stands about 20 feet away,
each have a key around their neck and they put the key in the lock
simultaneously and then turn it for 10 seconds and at the end of 10 seconds the
missile is gone.
And that's that.
And they both had their keys in the lock in 1962 so,
and we came close again in 1984 when,
I don't know if you know this,
but there's Soviet missile detection system signal.
The launch of four or five missiles from North America and a single Russian
soldier decided that it was a false alarm and refuse to push the button that
would have resulted in major retaliation.
He just died about a year ago.
You can read about him on Wikipedia.
Anyways,
I read soldier Nixon in 1970s and,
and I made me,
me even I would say more obsessed with what was happening in,
in on the world stage.
I was trying to understand why it was that
the systems of belief that we inhabited,
let's say one typifying the Soviet Union and in similar states,
Maoist China,
North Korea,
wonderful places like that versus the West.
We each had our own way of construing the world,
the ways of construing the world were set at odds with one another.
And the fact that they were set at odds with one another appeared to be so
significant that we'd armed ourselves with
50,000
yeah,
hydro hydrogen bombs on each side,
something like that.
And I don't know how much you know about hydrogen bomb.
You know,
you know about atomic bombs,
you know that a hydrogen bomb has an atomic bomb for the trigger,
right?
So,
so like the atom bomb that was dropped on Hiroshima,
that was something that was a fission bomb,
not standard atomic bomb,
the first generation,
but hydrogen bomb is incontestably more powerful than that.
And we were producing them in the tens of thousands.
It's not like we don't have any now,
but it was really some insanity in the 1980s and people seem to have a very
itchy trigger finger.
So I was very confused about this in two ways.
One from a psychological perspective,
because by that time I had just studied,
decided to study psychology instead of political science,
which was my original major.
I get,
I got disenchanted with political science because I didn't believe that people
were fundamentally motivated by economic issues.
I still don't believe that that's true.
They're motivated by whatever they're motivated by.
It can't be captured by economics,
not,
not precisely.
It's very curious about what it was that was so important about a belief system
that people would risk putting the entire planet to the torch to ensure that
their particular mode of construing the world prevailed was an interesting
psychological problem.
What was so important about belief system that would justify destroying
everything,
let's say,
or risking destroying everything,
because that was certainly the situation we put ourselves in.